I think I've just starting to say
congratulations on season 9 thank you
thank you do you ever think that the
show would get this far and and or did
you always believe in it really from the
hey no I believed in the show but I
guess like most people I figured it may
go two seasons or something I don't I
didn't know that we'd be completing a
season 80 moving on the season nine I
had no idea so I wouldn't want to sit
here and try to pretend to be the
resident genius that you know predicted
it all I had no idea zero
what do you think it is that audiences
love so much about the show though
there's always a negative if I really
think the real answer is if I knew it'd
be ten times as popular a thousand times
as popular because whatever that is I'd
add more of it yes but I guess you know
the camaraderie you know the fact that
the actors get alone behind the scenes
you know I think a lot of even a lot of
times a lot of television actors they
say they get along but they don't always
get that for me a lot of them say they
get along but they don't actually get
along and I think that reads on camera
and our group we actually do get along
um and we actually have a nice you know
a good relationship and I think that
that really helps you know because even
if someone's having a tough morning
non-coffee grumpy morning it doesn't
like completely disrupt the entire set
in the environment like we're able to
kind of compartmentalize yeah yeah
that's me so I think that's the thing
that helps you had such an amazing you
know last episode I mean it was it was
very heart-wrenching it was the action
was unbelievable your wife was murdered
yeah kidnap and talk about just about
that episode and how intense it was
shooting that yeah um well for me that
was the most dramatic the last two
episodes of the season would have two
most dramatic things that I've ever done
as an actor um and you know it was very
excuse me mm-hmm very fulfilling as an
artist but very uh challenging as a
human being you know that know that a
character is going through
going through it but uh you know it's
amazing that they would write something
like that and give us a chance to do
that kind of work you know on a
procedural you know because you when
most people think about procedurals they
think okay it's pretty cookie cutter and
this happens and that happens but this
actually gave me some real character
work deep deep care not real deep
character work and it was a profound
experience for me I really enjoyed it
and I think the whole crew did such the
whole cast is such an amazing job in
there and it you know respective roles
that it just took it to another level
and hope people enjoy it oh they did so
where do you go from here like what what
what can you tell us about next season I
know that's one of those questions that
we can't really get too much but well I
mean I don't know that's the real answer
I have absolutely no idea I might you
know come out you know in with leather
chaps or riding a unicorn I don't have
no idea to know in yes I mean but we'll
see I think that um look that we know
that all bets are off we know that my
character Sam Hanna is forever changed
um
engine is hard well yeah well I don't
know if the word revenge vengeance but
you know he achieved that for the most
part in the last episode of the season
but it's still that it's more about less
about the vengeance and anger and more
about as a human being how do you
recover from something so devastating
like losing someone really close to you
so we'll see how he responds to that and
how that affects his relationship with
the people around him which to me maybe
means that deeper acting that you
experienced in those last two episodes
is probably really going to bleed into
the next like if this is something now
you are in yeah yeah I think that he is
forever changed and I think that a layer
has been added or peeled away
according how you look at it yeah and
what we'll see so is gonna get the name
right is Tahiti is a te to here to here
it's clear really dead we don't know we
don't know I mean we saw you know he
definitely got his arm shot off mark yes
oh that's that but I don't know
what happens we saw you know the bus
explode we saw a zombie shot
but I don't we don't know we'll see
remains to be seen amazing the
relationship you talk a little bit about
that with the cast for this special you
and Chris O'Donnell have this thing was
that something you had to work at or did
it just really happen naturally over
time no you know we really get along and
you know Eric and Daniela as well oh you
know Kensi and Deeks and uh you know
heady and you know me recipe strange I
mean this whole crew really gets along
and those guys bring a lot of skill to
the table they bring a lot of energy and
passion to what we do and you know Chris
and I we just really figured out how to
you know coexist in a way that really is
healthy yeah you know it's a healthy
relationship and that's a good thing
because that's not always the case so um
you know still we got to have fun just
have fun enjoy it you know everything
that you do in your career you do with
passion and everyone can see that and we
can feel that lip sync battle
is so much fun and it's so great to
watch is there anyone you can tell us
who's coming up any any any bits of
mashups that we're going to play well
right now we're kind of in between
seasons um we're on hiatus as with NCIS
LA but we're gonna have some fun coming
up there's going to be some really good
stuff coming up I'm not sure exactly
I've been I've been hearing some names
kicking around and a lot of fun so it'll
get crazy and crazy coming out you must
genuinely have belly laugh like when you
I don't know every day it's out of
control I mean you know just get people
see people out of their comfort zone
yeah you know uh you know listening to
music that I don't normally listen to
what I'm going to know you're with yeah
I mean it's always something crazy and
different yeah you know people not
afraid to be silly
no we need we need more of that right
now it definitely will help he has me
helps I mean we've been uh it's been a
tough yeah it's been a little
challenging out there you know the
environment has been a little different
little little weird so it's nice to kind
of provide that relief but that's the
purpose of entertainment you know my job
is to help you forget about your
problems when you see me I want you to
think about joy and enjoyment and having
fun you know that I'm I don't really do
that I mean that's what I'm bringing to
the table yeah you do and you do it in
such a
way and I think that you know even when
you're out hosting as well I mean the
Grammys you're so fantastic
are you are you looking at other
opportunities like that to shine again
you know I get honestly I get
opportunities to host things all the
time I haven't pulled the trigger on
anything yet whenever I need a co-host
your your ring I'll make sure I would
you know we'll get it pop it alright you
know but you know was it was it that's
fantastic and you know you've been very
vocal on on social media sort of talking
with the artists and talking about music
and talking about respect
yeah what do you think of today's
musical climate and sort of the the
people who are making music currently
now I think there's you know like any
other period in history this'll there's
some garbage out there and some great
stuff out there
I mean that's just the nature of art
right there's always going to be
something you don't like and something
you love so um you know I mean some of
is terrible and some of his phenomenal
you know I mean it's all you know
case-by-case basis but I feel like there
needs to be more respect for legends
like yourself who have paved the way
sort of for everyone well you know I you
know I got to tell you I feel respected
you know I don't I don't you know I
don't I don't feel like I'm treated any
differently from Madonna or Mick Jagger
Paul McCartney yeah Bruce Springsteen
yeah you know LL Cool J like I don't
feel I feel great you know I feel like I
have I feel plenty of love feel great so
do you think the quality of the music
right now is good someone would be
better some of it I'm kind of it is
absolutely terrible and some of it's
phenomenal ya know you know I mean you
know you know somebody mumbling through
a overdose accost sir that's not only
great season to you know get it yeah you
know yeah poor course served on your arm
grab their interests bananas but then
some of its magnificent you know that's
you know you have people that are saying
insightful things and yeah conscious
things and things that really stimulate
your mind and sending great messages out
there so it's a it's a balance you know
I'm not a I'm not a uh I don't I don't
- modernity if that makes sense like I'm
not looking to like change what's going
on I think if you have something to say
about the music and you don't like if
the terrible music isn't good to you
then just make some new music you know
thinking of which you know are you going
are you going to go back in the
recording studio I don't know maybe one
day you know right now I'm kind of just
having fun doing am having fun doing
what I'm doing you know I know that my
music fans you know call for it
constantly and want me to know that they
want me to make some music and you know
it's not to say that I won't you know at
some point I might really commit but in
order for me to really get into the
music I have to really be focused on
that I don't want to treat it as a side
hustle um this is you know and right now
I'm committed to these shows and doing
what I'm doing so you know maybe at some
point I'll you know pull the trigger on
some new music and get it poppin